for the past six months my team and i
have been all over the country checking
out the best of your restaurant
nominations
now my nationwide competition continues
this time to find the best of british
british restaurants used to be all about
prawn cocktails and black forest gato
but today there are restaurants all over
the uk cooking the most amazing
delicious modern british food
every british restaurant should be using
the finest ingredients we have some of
the best meat fish and vegetables on the
planet so there's no excuse not to cook
with it
you nominated thousands of british
restaurants and along with my best
restaurant team i put them under extreme
scrutiny and chosen my two favorites to
do battle for a place in the semi-finals
from deepest kent it's a tiny but
elegant michelin-starred restaurant the
west house you get the next two twos
please it's always got to be that same
passion if you like drive from the first
time you made it they're going
head-to-head with the milestone in
sheffield well the watercress on very
last as it's going it's about yorkshire
people yorkshire chefs producing yogurt
food
we're about to see the battle of britain
because the west house and the milestone
must take on three extraordinary
challenges
the first is every restaurant's worst
nightmare 30 hungry customers who will
arrive and order all at once
first stop the milestone in sheffield
i'm actually standing on what used to be
called pimp's corner in the old red
light district now this is an amazing
location for a fantastic restaurant it's
run by four local lads front of house
are the owners mark and matt who've sunk
every penny into this business one
salmon one black putty on an order the
kitchen is headed by young guns simon
and james
simon
cage fighter
no one [ __ ] with you or service do they
these guys are real they craft us you
can see that just from the minute you
shake their hands it's solid like a
plate of sheffield steel
i love the fact that they've made their
name by breaking all the rules serving
up hearty organic dishes like rolled
pigs head and trotter sausages and
what's that they're our own
pigs that we have it's a farm just
outside sheffield right bring your own
pigs and you guys on the menu
yeah we encourage customers to actually
go out there and get their hands dirty
and start foraging for us we'll swap it
for beer wine or a meal it's my mum's
allotment and she's picked them all by
hand especially for you guys
in just three years the milestone of
storm sheffield's restaurant scene and
the locals love it there aren't a great
deal of restaurants especially in
sheffield are doing food with this
quality food is amazing great
environment i'll go for the nestle nokia
[Music]
nice and it's made on the
nettle gnocchi there's a lot of nettle
in there isn't that yeah the knock is
delicious
pretty good indeed i think what i like
more than anything is the fact that it's
very seasonal very nice
i thought that food was easily of a
mission star standard today you've got a
chance to become the best of british
show off i mean really show off people
used to dealt with because i'm a youth
and they used to think i wear a cocky
little [ __ ] but i'm passionate i'm
dedicated and i've got the drive to take
it further
good because my diners are expecting
something incredible and they all need
to be served two courses in just two
hours
this is a young dynamic restaurant
that's going places give that experience
to my 39ers today and they'll be leaving
on cloud9
any questions don't hesitate to ask
i suppose it's just
it's just a little bit quirky
the starters include black pudding with
bloody mary
cucumber and ginsu with cured salmon
and the pea panna cotta
it's the p pentagon represents the first
sort of peacock to spring it's a really
nice summary option and the idea is
rather than choose the more adventurous
options most diners are sticking to the
traditional fare
homemade black footage please
please
it looks like we're gonna have a lot of
black put in an order it's good that
there's such a popular choice on the
menu but the punters might not want it
once they've been served this first of
all from the kitchen today we have an
amused food for you
so it's a little appetizer homemade
chicken and black pudding to me there
seems to be a lot of black pudding
coming out of the kitchen
yeah but they're already starting off
with that building as well did not
anyone tell them that beforehand or not
no no
if they're giving away uh black pudding
as a canape yeah they should have said
it before they took the orders there's
so much back pudding going out yeah so
we go first two courses black pudding
black pudding i'd only eat black pudding
twice
with sheffield people they're like
really heavy dishes as well they're like
they like that meaty flavor that's not a
small slice of black pudding is it the
man-sized one
i wasn't too keen on the black pudding i
thought it was really nice was just too
much for me to be honest it's on to the
mains simon's ambitious food includes
turbot poached and red wine nettle
gnocchi and pan-fried rabbit loin with
pigtail cannon only don't need to be
going on stage for once in all fairness
jay all in yeah yeah simon has made the
unusual decision to operate this service
like a banquet instead of staggering the
dishes he's preparing all the main
courses at the same time so it's going
to go everything away the problem now is
that simon has all the rabbit dishes
ready but the other main courses are
lagging behind and food can't leave the
pass until the order for the whole table
is cooked as it sits in the window and
dries out i'm just getting nervous i
don't want a fruit coming back saying
it's dry you've got one hour ten minutes
left so if you can just do one table at
a time you'll see a difference in
quality it's not
the fastest restaurant in britain i'm
looking for the best restaurant
not good enough two hours
30 diners two courses only so stagger
them like a normal service it's a shame
it's just sat there disintegrating under
those lights when it should be in front
of the customer and they're getting that
magic there and then
it's adam is it possible
with a little bit hotter in fact a lot
harder
these are my worst fears come true when
food sits too long in the past it gets
cold it gets dry it gets sent back so
that's exactly what i was trying to say
it's not a banquet and everyone's got it
in their mind that we're going to treat
this today like a banquet such a [ __ ]
shame
the rabbit lying the place not hot they
can't play it can have another rabbit
like nope
now simon's in trouble there is no
rabbit loin left so thinking fast he
substitutes it with rabbit leg but he's
starting from scratch and the leg takes
longer to cook than the loin so we're
short of one portion
do you guys want to explain that to the
customer i i just yeah the rabbit's
still raw there that's what i'm trying
to say
[Music]
oh thank you you're welcome
this one looks like you've just throwing
it together
this don't even look like that no man
this is not cooked well enough for me i
don't eat my meat like this we want it
done a little bit more for you i wanted
more than done a little bit more this is
all cooked
having tried and failed twice matt the
owner wants to make amends can i get you
anything no well only because these guys
are eating obviously your experience has
been as i've been up to scratch a bit of
fish
are you okay no problem i'm fine i'll
say that when you get eaten
sorry guys enjoy it's let down what was
otherwise a great service
it's absolutely delicious really really
good it's a really interesting
combination of textures i'd rather the
service probably nine out of ten food is
immense absolutely immense no complaints
whatsoever one little tiny bit of
service just got us
starters by boosh bye
mains all going fine until
that 1.1 table
yeah
[Music]
most of the diners leave happy but i've
got concerns
[Music]
okay
uh right how do you feel not horribly
happy mistakes i've made um i think
we've got to learn from them yeah
whose decision was it
to serve
my diners as a banquet
in mind when all the checks came on i
made a decision because all of them were
having starters yeah so i was going to
try and sweep the room yep said one
course second course third course that
was a big mistake for me today for every
30 seconds that food is sat there it's
going down and down and down and down in
standard but you've got a dream set up
because your customers are sat two
meters away from your stove and it was
such a shame because then food came back
because it wasn't hot enough the good
news is the customers love the food and
that's what i'm trying to say you're on
the verge of just really popping out
there you wear your own pigs you make
your fresh bread twice a day so you bust
your balls to create that food and when
it sits there
and they're not benefiting god i could
scream
you're doing yourselves an injustice
and that responsibility is on your
shoulder sign because you're the head
chef i know
and i know
you can do a lot better than what you
did today
thank you thank you well done
we're always looking to improve lessons
learned yeah we're young and ambitious
we want to be the best we can look at
what mistakes we did and not allow them
to happen again
it's the british heat of my nationwide
restaurant competition and a squad of
hungry diners are about to descend on my
second competitor
from thousands of your nominations i've
chosen the west house from biddington in
kent
how are you
good to see you too right where is he
everywhere in the kitchen
good to see you thank you i met graham
15 years ago when he worked next door to
my first london restaurant even then he
showed real flair the idea is to build
dishes around the central ingredient and
you know not fan around with it too much
not chuck too many other things on the
plate and try and enhance you know bring
out the flavors graham hasn't always
been a chef
he started out as a drummer for 80s hair
rockers yaya
no i've never heard of them either
[Music]
he still has some of the hair but
happily not the shorts luckily i've done
that for a long time various tours and
albums and all sorts got to see the
world and eating a lot of restaurants as
well which is quite good
[Music]
17 years ago graham gave up rock and
roll to follow his dream of becoming a
chef working in a string of top london
restaurants
then eight years ago he took a huge risk
he moved his family to the ken
countryside and opened up the west house
18 months after opening he won his first
mission star
that's not bad for a drummer and when
you won the mission start were you on
your own in the kitchen wow so it's a
one-man band back to play the drums
again
everything about this family russian is
understated old english charm
graham's partner jackie works front of
house with their children jake and jess
who's in charge it'll be me
happy being in charge
yeah
that means a polite note
at the beginning i didn't know what i
was doing and uh now eight years on it's
not as bad as it was but i didn't like
it at first no i'll start off with the
hammered eggs it's very um very clean
really nice flavors pop it on the menu
yeah yeah very i can imagine why what i
like most about west house is the fact
that graham is a is a true chef he cooks
from the heart
not into frills he's into flavor and it
shows
this quaint english restaurant is about
to be severely tested because my diners
will soon be arriving and ordering all
at the same time
my worst fear is ill-going too so
basically i'm just expecting the whole
family to put in an amazing performance
today to pull this one off just like the
milestone they have just two hours to
serve everyone this little 11 table
restaurant is going to be packed you
have a michigan star
so myself and my diners are expecting
experience there
there's a three and two twos now as soon
as you can get the first table yeah i'll
see you both ready order
one had it one round
three
that looks like air traffic control up
there what is that huh i'm getting there
i've never seen tickets written like
that before okay
can i have bread on tin okay what is
that there
that's one one ham hog and one mackerel
yeah jesus christ the tickets are
confusing but the food coming out of the
kitchen is simply perfect
starters include warm smoked haddock
carpaccio with bacon dressing and pea
shoes and that delicious ham hock with
scotch egg and black pudding
how's the um ham hock in piccadilly
really good enjoying it really delicious
these are amazing yeah the little scotch
eggs with black pudding yeah
so first main courses is coming up now
jake griddle's gonna be busy today isn't
it it's gonna be a bit annoying so
you're griddling nokia as well it's the
first one for me i've never seen that
before just to color it off then it gets
tossed through with the artichokes for
maine's there's a choice of roast
chicken with herb gnocchi
grilled with samphire or lamb with
sweetbreads
there's three of you in here no one out
there i'm nervous
[Music]
how many waters taken just left there
why would you just dump an order there
like that
i'm finding the ordering system
impossible to fathom and jackie's
handwriting is more like a doctor's than
a maitre d no one can read it that's one
hat
one had it yeah
i rewrote the ticket out and
then picked that up as well and he'd
already sent it it was my fault i left
it on there because it was but he
couldn't understand my writing so
it's my fault
today was the [ __ ] day to do it
okay table ten two chicken what that
table is one and five and
two lamb look the two
jackie's supposed to be in control of
front of house but it doesn't feel like
it
something's not right the service isn't
as i'd imagine from a michigan style
restaurant we've been here about 40
minutes and
aside from the drinks order we haven't
had seen the staff going to get take any
orders for food
there's five tables in there that still
haven't had their order taken right it
just you shout what orders to get he's
telling you when to take the orders at
the moment yeah
get three i'll get two free to get
together table three yeah you tell them
when to take the orders right that's
right
there's people that have already eaten
one course i think at least so it's
hoping that we might get
asked what we would like to order soon
there are tables there watching starters
main courses being served and yet they
haven't had the order taken yeah you
wouldn't normally have 30 in the
restaurant at once would you so
but they haven't had the order taken let
alone just things a little bit
outside the title
the dining room's controlled by the
kitchen so
they're rudderless they can't do
anything unless the kitchen says so
which is just crazy they need to
function
control freak it's not control freaky
it's trying to stay focused i'm sorry it
is because you're not in the dining room
so they're all sat there staring at your
teeth you're dying right so control
freak all right i've never seen anything
so stupid in all my life chefs don't
tell waiters when to take an order
that's the responsibility of the dining
room to give it to the chef he's trying
to control [ __ ] everything
does ben know how to do main courses as
well
no not yet not yet
eight months in this kitchen working
alongside you and you can't do a main
course yet i think is you don't want to
tell them it you know that no it's time
you know there's a lot to do over there
sorry about the delay for these starters
just over an hour how are they
lovely it's really very nice yeah thank
you waited far too long um drinks
we ordered some drinks before they took
our order and we haven't had them right
drinks and even before we started taking
their order and nothing's hit the table
yet
drinks on the throne
they're not lying let's put it that way
but they're just saying of all the
drinks and nothing's happening sorry
to give control back to the front of
house i can see a solution
if you'd like it different i can go and
get that cooked fur before let me place
everything on it because everything's
cold now okay right yeah graham's son
jake is on top of things yeah it'll just
be a few minutes just be doing it for
you okay
yeah i will do wouldn't you be best
running a day
you seem to be the only one that
actually knows
how to do it properly i don't know
that's not been disparaging to mum but
you seem to know what you're doing sort
of i wanted to do it mine in his way and
she's got a little that way but he
seemed to be he won't break out he
seemed to know
yeah and his service be a lot smoother
we've had somebody running it
it was tough it's tough
good couldn't you tell
the food was absolutely delicious i
think the only thing that wasn't really
up to standard was the the service it
was worth the wait then that's that's
the good thing
oh [ __ ] that
my diners have no complaints about the
food because the cooking is inspiring
but graham is tripping up the service
and he has to understand this
okay
here's the issue
unfortunately
okay
the service
is nowhere near to the standard of food
you left two tables
you know sat there for over an hour
before we even took their order
and
the dining room felt
short stuffed food sent to the same
table twice the star's already gone
jackie across the two hours you didn't
give me the impression that you were
enjoying it as much as you should off
are you
a hundred percent happy
running that dining room
on a normal day yeah on a normal day but
today i was a bit
you know panicking right now yeah jay
you were the one shining light out there
and why you're not at the helm
relieving the pressure from your mother
and working closely with your father
i'll never know you've sort of castrated
the dying room
because you're controlling them you've
got to cut
some of the control freak in you and
allow them to do their job and you'll be
surprised at the results i'm telling you
because i want this place to really
succeed in this competition why because
the food is beautiful
well done
it's like any any criticism you
you take it on board then you filter it
through and uh
and react so yeah i mean there's some
there's some food for full
i'm looking for the best restaurant not
the best chef and
service is crucial today customers are
prepared to wait but they're not
prepared to wait for an hour to get
their order taken no chance
[Music]
by pushing both restaurants to extremes
i've uncovered the areas they need to
improve on
now i've invited them both to london for
a progress report but the restaurants
haven't got a clue that they face one
more test without telling them i sent in
my secret diners because i really want
to find out exactly what happens when
the teams don't know they're under
scrutiny
i've sent in top food critic simon davis
with instructions to be as difficult as
possible something that comes quite
naturally to him
the teams don't know that i've been
spying on them first to face the music
is the milestone
i wanted to make sure that you weren't
just rolling out the red carpet for me
i had
a secret diner in there and this is what
he saw
hello we'll grab some lunch did we just
you just grab a seat do you okay great i
love that i love the fact you do
dripping
ready to start actually such a good idea
the dripping you have your roast and
then the dripping you'd have throughout
the week
spread on the bread
cheerful
slightly nostalgic really nice and look
how happy
yeah customers sound really good all
right this is ox tongue corned beef
nowhere near seasoned or not
very bland
that's quite disappointing actually
it's such a shame because
the diner shot up wow dripping exit and
then back oh [ __ ] when you've got the
balls to put corned beef and oxton on a
plate that simply
it has to be seasoned perfectly we've
actually changed that already because
we've read the comment card that night
seasoning
it was essentially a lack of seasoning
yeah yeah
you know thanks a lot
oh really well i wasn't expecting that i
know i perfectly
[Music]
no charge nice gesture gives him no
reason to complain about it i love the
way he was so patient and so polite
really polite
on several occasions we've seen some
really
succinct
um very focused ability in the kitchen
with very well sourced food and then you
get things like these this bowl of chips
you know
pubs not even places that claim to call
themselves gastropubs that serve better
chips
burnt chips it's a simple
stupid mistake that shouldn't really
happen ever can i have a word with a
chef
it's a chef chef around
yeah
well no i want to talk to you about
something i'm talking about that look at
that would you eat that
would you eat that
no so why should i eat it
well no i want to talk to chef
don't me too much now okay
how about the dessert menu yeah i'd love
to all right hi there brilliant well
they're gone now but i wanted to talk to
you later i've noticed
like two or three traditions that i'm
trying to teach right on how to
cook issues
[Music]
i just wondered why you allowed that
chip to go out when it was burnt in
there
[Music]
i thought you were going to blow a
gasket to be honest i could cry i could
cry
a chip
goes out like it's
on the back of an ass end of a a
takeaway van there's flashes of
brilliance in there and it works in such
a magical way and that you bust your
balls fresh bread rearing peaks cooking
skills you know slow down
and focus on what you've got
the chips were burned they shouldn't
have been burnt they should have been
absolutely fine they should have been
fantastic the guy should have been
picking him out of the ball saying my
god these are [ __ ] amazing chips i've
seen a lot of problems that we do need
to solve but we've also seen a lot of
strengths that we know we have got
so as long as we bring everything
together tighten it up i think we can
improve and we can make things
better than they ever have been
graham and his family team from the west
house are about to discover that i've
been spying on them
i sent in undercover diner sarah durden
robertson she's a cookie writer and a
food consultant
[Music]
when i sent my 30 diners into the west
house mum jackie confused everyone with
her ordering system have things improved
since
unknown to all four of you you've
actually been under two tests because
after i left i sent in a secret diner
and here's what they saw
do you make the bread here yeah all the
breads made every morning comes down at
eight o'clock usually who the chef yeah
thanks for the bad side oh god he makes
bread smells delicious
especially the brown one i really like
the brown fruit in that one he seems
quite proud of his father and what they
do because he talks about them with
great affection
i kind of feel like i'm sitting in the
family kitchen
it's made it all a lot more personal
actually really good lovely start
oh
no
now what is this again what did i do
before i go to park watering
i think i ordered a mackerel
excuse me
oh that's okay i thought i'd go mad for
a second
oh
they're not busy how could you confuse
the two tables
should remember what's going on
damn
watching your food being put down on a
table in front of you is like eating
secondhand food whenever that
happens again the food goes back into
the kitchen i forgot that
how'd you feel watching that
bit gutted that i messed it up so i
could go and write those tickets for you
now and show you the correct procedure
and what ways could be so much easier
for you do me a favor do that because
i've been trying to do that for about
eight years but i get ignored my vision
listen to you yeah
so i ordered the
um
the interesting thing is they didn't ask
me how i wanted the lamb done
so i'm afraid when it arrives i may
discover i've got a problem with it
ah thank you
i'm sorry to be prepared i didn't
realize that the lamb came so quick
would it be possible to have one passer
done uh yeah i'll just go see thank you
surely you must ask a customer
medium pink well done
no that's their promotive
it's not this old 1980s shepherd
mentality what i say goes and it saves
the frustration doesn't it it saves that
dish being done twice oh thank you
and the chicken we'll just be right back
thank goodness
so they've brought
two completely new main courses rather
than bringing back the half cold first
place they've brought back an entirely
new main course
that is
very impressive
great recovery
wonderful recovery the fact that you
took time and done two new main courses
yeah pain in the ass of the kitchen but
you did it
without any hassle and left a really
nice impression
despite the fact that they actually
ended up cooking four main courses
they've only charged for one each so
it's 48 pounds ahead
food is just
experience phenomenal food delicious
value for money spot on i want to come
back here because it felt like they're
coming to your house if you get up to
speed with the modern day system of
taking tickets it doesn't need to be
that pressurized putting those dishes
down so we have to look at the
disorganization that's it
you know i came straight back in the
kitchen and told graham what had done
i remember and i was so gutted that i'd
done it you know because as i said in
eight years i've never made that mistake
before it would be fantastic to sit
there and see that secret footage and
there'd be absolutely not a single thing
wrong sit there and pat each other on
the back and leave but life's not really
like that is it
graham's putting a brave face on things
but he must realize he's got a lot of
work to do if he's going to win this
competition
i put both teams through the ringer to
test their skills as chefs and
restaurateurs
now it's their last chance to prove
themselves
[Music]
to earn a place in the semi-finals
they've got to cook one exceptional dish
something worthy of a place on my three
michelin style menu
i'd be alive i said i've slept well last
night because just running everything
through over and over and over in your
head it's just all the pre-match nerves
and i saw pretty much tension
quite daunting never been in a place
quite like this
it's a mixture of excitement and nerves
i want to win more than anything i've
got to get everything absolutely right
so it all rides on this really good luck
to earn the honor of representing
british cuisine in the semi-finals their
dish must be nothing less than
exceptional
[Music]
this is the battle of britain and for me
two of the best restaurants
are going head to head for the very
first time there's no undercover footage
there's no coach it's just you on a
plate it's 20 stunning dishes and that
is it
make sure
as you go through the semi-final good
luck
[Music]
i've asked them to create their dishes
using a classic british ingredient
venison
these are two amazing restaurants coming
head to head and for me the best of
british always exciting more than any
other category i'm expecting great
flavors great balance and phenomenal
fireworks
i've invited 20 esteemed guests to judge
both teams creations
the diners include elizabeth carter
editor of the good food guide
and award-winning british farmer wilfred
emmanuel jones
and the front of house teams from both
restaurants are here too so in terms of
nerves and skeletal turn why
11 11.
this is our last chance to prove
ourselves
on all the forecasts table two
west house four venison line
graham's devised a dish worthy of his
michelin-starred status
he's using venison loin
served with onion marmalade potatoes
pickled cherries and finished with
crispy bacon and venison liver it's hard
to gear because the hammers breakfast
they call it they tend to make this part
it's got a great flavor you know but you
need to keep it nice and nice and rare
[Music]
it's a technical dish with the potential
for disaster especially if graham's
control freakery prevents sous chef ben
from supporting him i know what you're
lying yeah you won't let anyone do
anything what are you actually doing
today apart from making green tea are
you actually participating in the
cooking yeah definitely i'm doing all
the garnish looking off the christmas
bacon potatoes honey marmalade cherries
and i'll plate as well if you let me
i know you love taking your time when
you put these dishes together it's
actually one hour for 20 not one hour
per dish yeah just in case because i
know what you like when you get buried
away there's no pulling your bag out
there is there
my face of grain is that the food is so
complex there's four or five elements so
he just needs to offload and open up and
bring ben with him to get that dish
absolutely perfect
so for more venison loin away now graham
please west house on table two please
ben
send one table clean your [ __ ] down send
the next table clear your [ __ ] down yeah
what i'll do ben i'm going to leave
these for you to play the last while i
could deliver
it
graham's delegating at last but with
time on his hands he started cooking the
delicate venison liver too early
that liver is yours your danger zone you
know that grain i do danger zone
how do you want to serve it i want to
show it really yeah so you cook it rare
here it goes out there pink when it sits
there it's firm as [ __ ] do you
understand so when he's two thirds of
the plate dress and you're happy have
the confidence just to fry that at the
last moment
tell me when i'm going liver yeah yep
you ready uh yeah go for it
two livers in yeah here
and try and stand those cherry stems up
please
they look fantastic absolutely fantastic
no two ways about it go please table two
two more venison away now please graeme
with chef table four please thank you
i'm working well as a team at the moment
i mean it's great ben's getting involved
with stuff on the path allowing me to
cook the liver of things last minute
graham's happy with his food but will
the diners agree
[Music]
it smells absolutely super smells really
lovely
the flavors are all there i mean exactly
what we always get in the restaurant i'm
very proud of him yeah
it's a good dish it looks good as well
boys are gonna nail it
graham's dish has set the bar seriously
high to being with a chance of winning
the milestone lads really have a battle
on their hands so on order four covers
table six milestone four venison
wellington yes yeah thank you big
competition today going head-to-head
against the michigan star ration yeah
you've got no cooking school today no
downstairs no upstairs no one kitchen 20
diners no excuses what's the chances i'm
optimistic i am yeah i think we're going
to do it
obviously they've got a michelin star we
haven't so sort of the underdogs but if
we can do this then they'd be amazing
head chef simon is pulling out all the
stops with a ballsy dish of rose venison
loin and a haunch of venison and nettle
wellington served with beetroot fondant
watercress puree and braised lettuce
this could be the dish in my career if
all goes well then it could change
things for us drastically how far you
off simon six minutes seven six yeah six
seven six yeah
simon's dish requires perfect timing
something he messed up when he fed my
coach diners
[Music]
i'd rather keep the customers waiting
next to five minutes yeah the server
beetroot that's not cooked properly
there's no room for mistakes all six
elements of this dish must be cooked to
perfection i fall venison up to the past
now
guys make every plate count yeah
good happy say this yep go please
but in his haste to get the food out
simon has made a terrible schoolboy
error
[Music]
how'd you forget that lettuce
i'm [ __ ] up tell me come on you should
know that by now get me rob please
urgently let's go uh that's the braised
lettuce that we've got off the main cut
it's fine it's not on there now they
haven't finished it then i'm not even
halfway through it go please yeah yeah
just apologize quickly thank you
[ __ ]
that's following awesome
behind us a braised baby gem lettuce
a more experienced chef would recover
from a mistake like this quickly but
simon's rattled
i missed it off the plate i saw him
pissed off i'm pissed off at myself look
at me look at me i said he's gone yeah
yep you can pull it back come on one
more table let's go yeah thank you yes
chef
30 seconds venison will be up first
right coming up on this yeah yeah oh
watch up lights up
[Music]
at this time the lettuce is on the plate
yeah not separate table one please yeah
say this
start working up another forward yeah
yeah simon's bounced back and he's
talking to james and more importantly
they're together as a team so it's a
dynamic duo as opposed to one up one
down
happy with that yeah say this
very nice the dishes look fantastic
absolutely delicious james yeah time to
keep it going yeah yeah
that's your last table yes
make the last table look exactly and
tastes exactly the same as the first
please yeah
gently
okay good off we go
rusty loin venison nettle wellington
thank you
it looks absolutely brilliant it smells
divine i must admit
this is just spectacular incredibly
succulent
flavors
really good here hold on guys yeah
yeah big deep breath
nice one
service is over my discerning guests
have tasted both restaurants food i want
to find out what they thought starting
with a milestone
let's talk the venison with wellington
wonderful combination of flavours the
texture
the taste
it really worked for me wilfred how was
it the person who did the wellington i
would he is so eager to win yeah he
looks like a cage fighter i feel like
he's ready for action
and you could see that in the dish there
was too much going on and then the one
with cherry was a bit more laid back
yeah this is the west house that was my
preference and it's because i wasn't
trying too hard i preferred the west
house and i thought the way they cut the
venison was perfect and i absolutely
love the liver which is something i
normally don't eat and was a real treat
i referred the wellington
yeah i thought it was actually fantastic
i thought the pastry was brilliant it
was really light extremely difficult to
choose yes actually a bit like two
beautiful ladies you
brigades have performed well but they've
also
come up against pressure
gordon doesn't miss anything does he
he's just
eyes on everything
i think overall it went really really
well yeah the food looks amazing we
tasted every dish that went out so
hopefully
that'll be the winning dish i'm hoping
for the best but it's all in the eyes of
gordon at the end of there both of these
restaurants have great strengths but
they've also both got flaws
i'd love to put them both through to the
semi-finals but i can't which of them
has the potential to be truly great i've
got to decide
my top two british restaurants the
michelin-starred west house from kent
and the milestone from sheffield have
absolutely cooked their hearts out
i'm about to tell one of them their
competition journey ends here
there have been errors yet both still
produce truly outstanding food
to help me make my choice i need to
compare both dishes
[Music]
both issues visually stunning i can
transport these two plates and put them
in any top restaurant and they wouldn't
look out of place that's how excited i
am about the best of british milestone
braised lettuce beetroot a wellington
done with a cheap gut
phenomenal and the nettle pancake
mind blowing
it's delicious buttery
slightly gamey loin of medicine that
just
just melts in your mouth it's just like
put a knife through butter it's that
soft wonderful
west house got that wow factor
delicious
god so hard
liver very difficult to get right it's
got that little touch of gaming
bitterness to it that really goes well
with the rich cut from the loin
seasoned beautifully the cherries make
it work because the acidity
and it's got that side of
that moorish sumptuous richness i am
really taking back by these dishes the
standard is incredible
i love this one love it love it love it
but then there's magic in this one for
me right now
they're both winners
[Music]
two remarkable british restaurants
but only one can win a place in the
semi-finals
okay um
i invited
both of you here today to
blow me away
for one restaurant to excel
um i didn't get that
no
because i got both restaurants excelling
in a big way
and it's
amazing to see
that kind of performance
in what
my mind is one of the most exciting
categories
but the joy of watching
and tasting what you've just done in
there
has now become
a nightmare on a personal front because
i have to eliminate one of you and put
one of you through to the semi-final
so i thought well which dish would i put
on my lunch menu tomorrow morning i came
up with the decision
both of the dishes would sit there
that's what i'm faced with right now so
the winner
is not based on one dish
because if it was
both of you would be going through think
of the journey i turn up with a coach 30
diners come
swooping in causes havoc
and it's the biggest pain in the ass
that any restaurant could ever wish for
i then film you
undercover i send an awkward secret
diner to turn the place upside down to
see how you handle that kind of pressure
here's my question
which restaurant
would i prefer to return to
west as would i go to that intimate
stunning
family-run michelin star
done with charm
or would it be the sheffield
i suppose balls of steel because it is
run with a
heartbeat that is missing a lot of
restaurants tough
very tough
it is so hard you've got no idea
the restaurant going through to the
semi-final based on everything i've seen
is
[Music]
milestone congratulations
[Music]
that was for me one of the toughest most
difficult decisions i've ever made but
that dish was unique and don't stop
cooking like that yeah
going out this stage as far as i'm sure
makes us you know
at worst the second best british
restaurant in the competition so you
know we carry on we do we do what we do
at the restaurant and you know keep the
customers happy and that's that's the
main thing
[Music]
uh guys well done
really well done yeah phenomenal you
pulled out the subs there today and it
worked yeah good job well done well done
well done
it's just amazing it's fantastic it's a
dream come true it's proved a point to
us for
and to a lot of other people that are
expecting a lot from us and
thank god we've actually come through
and we've we've made it with that kind
of determination that's where the future
of british cooking is up there in
sheffield
but right now this competition is only
going to get tougher and i hope they
don't let me down